congratulations by the way on becoming a
dad that must
how do you feel about it so far how do
you like the fatherhood how do i feel
about it
i kind of have to pinch myself sometimes
it's so it's so crazy like my wife
bless her she sends me so many updates
through the day just because you know
which that's sort of the month away um
she's about three and a half months now
old and uh i just look at i'm just like
holy moly that's that's like
that's my little human i gotta look
after her for the rest of my life and
it's it's absolutely amazing well three
and a half months old how old do you
think
she's gonna have to be as her father how
do you think she's gonna have to be
before you
start her ninja training because you can
train her to be an
oh it's inbuilt in her she's ready she
already has it she has that x factor
um no to be honest like she as soon as
she
she was born she was so aware of her
surroundings which is like really crazy
we have a
really good friend with a baby of who's
two weeks older
and um they're not as responsive and
they're not as kind of aware
um so she's yeah she's she's got some
skills already
so i wouldn't be surprised if she out
ninjas me at some point
oh it's gonna happen don't be surprised
it's always the way
for sure well you are playing
one of the most prominent ninjas i think
like in the entire world say guys
this is really cool and i know a lot of
people have said this too that they grew
up
playing with the toys watching the shows
um reading the comic books
but it must have been a real trip to be
able to go okay i'm going to tell the
story
of this character that nobody knows yeah
yeah you know it it's it's one of those
iconic characters that have been
passed down through generations you know
when the first sort of comics came out
and
uh larry hammer and the guys like
created
so many memorable characters um there's
a generation that passed it down to
their kids and
you know gave them the toys and now it's
it's sort of
uh we have the chance of passing this
this amazing character to a brand new
generation and so
we really wanted to start from sort of
dot one we needed to see um
snake eyes before uh we see him as the
person that we know him as that kind of
deadly weapon the assassin the
the commando uh the operator we need to
see him as a human we need to see him
without the mask on we need to
understand his motivations
um in in why he's the way that he is and
and the decisions that he had to make to
become
that bad it's already very clear from
the trailer that the chemistry between
you and andrew is off
the charts what was it like working with
him and also because the two
are creating this backstory for these
two iconic characters what was it like
working with him to do that
you know if craziest thing with uh me
and andrew is
we kind of grew up in the
tiniest town just outside of london
called ryga he went to college um in
ryde and i grew up in
in sort of uh red hill and ryegate um
and being like two of the only half
asian kids
like we we're in the same movie together
we're about the same age we are actually
in the same year at school so it's it's
crazy that we never bumped into each
other then
but to find ourselves filming like this
amazing film
halfway across the world in in tokyo and
in japan um
it was just so many sort of moments
of i suppose fate and um
and so we really understand each other's
energy
and i think he is such a different guy
from from who i am
and vice versa but we found this
sort of yin and yang kind of purpose and
that and that plays into
uh the relationship of snake eyes and
and
storm shadow because it is one of them
the most renowned
kind of back and forth relationships
that uh that has ever been written
one minute they're fighting together the
next minute their arch nemesis
uh then the next moment they're kind of
fighting together for
for for a bigger purpose um so
the the chemistry between us is
is is amazing it's absolute fireworks
especially
when we're back-to-back fighting uh
with each other against sort of uh the
enemy
i'm betting actually goosebumps just
your description of that like i love i
love the idea of that as a scene
you know when you're talking about um
working with a scene partner there's
always a talk of like you have to really
trust each other
in order to be able to get where you
need to go um with a script
right uh and subtext but how does that
apply to when you guys are actually
doing stunt work
and fight choreography together is it
the same idea
yeah i mean you have to drill those
fight scenes until you both can do it
like with your eyes closed um so me and
andrew spent
many many an afternoon a whole day uh
together with the amazing stunt team
cardiac um choreographing sort of i
can't even speak now
but going through the choreography so we
know it inside out
so that if on the day uh we just haven't
turned up the set
and the environment's different we need
to be able to be able to sort of adapt
and change like on the go almost
instantaneously
um and so it is like such a sort of uh
it's a dance between two actors and
and if you're not a good dance partner
it affects the entire scene so you have
to be a
you know at your best as much as
the other actor has to be at their best
it looks very complicated the
choreography you've got
swords going left right and center
rolling from one side to the next
and look it looks like there's a hundred
people on screen when you're doing some
of those action sequences
you know even even the best stunt guys
can slip
up and get hurt was there an instance
where you were like
you got i mean this is getting hurt
there's there's always little moments
where
you'll get a you'll get a stray sword
over the face or
somebody will like stub their finger or
i'll blow out my knee on on a particular
move or
you know when we're filming outside in
the cold in the in the sort of the dead
of winter
and you're not you know there's a lot of
waiting around when it comes to filming
but uh
wedding around is like your worst enemy
because your muscles start seizing up
um and then you have to go into this
explosive routine
um so you pull your muscles you you
still crank
on your uh your tendons and um but to be
honest with you
there wasn't anything overly too serious
with
uh with the injuries i kind of messed up
my hip a little bit
i i tore like a little bit of my quad
and my knees sort of like because we
have to sit in those
really low stances for for a long time
and it was kind of
your body adapts very very quickly but
we were so lucky like we
we had the best stunt team like looking
after us making sure we knew exactly
what we were doing that we were safe
um that you know you can't control the
outside
uh variables like if if we're running
down
sort of a dock and it's
slippery or things like that like
there's always
room for for a little bit of human error
you know you must have been prepared
mentally knowing how tough the training
was going to be
but looking back at having completed it
all
like do you kind of feel a little bit
like a superhero yourself afterwards
like yo i should be honest i did that
i did i miss it i miss it so much
because
it was so pure in training because we
gave
a hundred and ten percent like each and
every one of the actors like
dedicated themselves for at least two
two and a half months
um it was day in day out routine we knew
exactly what we were doing we were there
to like
prep ourselves to prep our bodies to get
in sync with each other
um to learn the sort of the the moves
and the intricacies that we need to like
pull off
all of the fight scenes for ourselves of
course we had like amazing
um stunt guys and stunned women um who
took the big hits for us
we're not allowed to jump off buildings
and uh off flaming cars
um it's kind of frowned upon uh in the
insurance world
um but we we needed to be able to do
every single one of those routines and
so i i released some of the uh the
training footage
uh a couple days ago and uh it you know
we would go through those routines
like one after the one after the other
one after the other for at least
three four hours um and then it's to a
point where we could
you know right at the beginning of
training it might have taken
45 minutes to learn a single bit of
choreography but we got to a point
where we could pick it up in like five
minutes like if we just went through
the moves and then we'd hit like 80
speed
like really really quickly so what
you're saying is just consistently do it
every single day like when i wake
up pick up the katana blade and get to
work it's like
everything like you have to put in the
hours you have to put in the sweat
the blood the tears um and and you
see a rapid rapid sort of rise in in
your levels of
kind of capacity that's awesome i know
joe fans are
are super interested in seeing you know
where the story goes
how the bigger broader jedi universe
gets included we see
scarlet and baroness in this as well can
you tell us about their inclusion in the
story
yeah um we we get the introduction to
both parties so we understand who the gi
joes are
and the relationship with them and cobra
i can't give away too much as to how
they're introduced
but it's an unraveling story and it's a
real
sort of testament to who snake is
because he finds himself kind of
trying to get to grips with this entire
world that he's just been
introduced to like he needs to figure
things out he's one of those guys that
um he's been relying on himself this
entire time
um to fend for himself to support
himself to kind of
to drive himself forward uh but to be
thrust
into a moment where he is responsible
for people
and those people are responsible for him
it's a weird feeling and so we see that
uh develop as we go through the uh the
movie
you seem to be really in love with all
the process of putting this film
together and the the physical thing is
something that's incredible to me that
like um
you go through all this rigorous
training and you just love the purity of
it is this something you could see
yourself doing a role you can see
yourself doing
like for a decade i mean it's it's a
no-brainer like i
loved loved loved loved uh playing in
that world
it's just so much fun especially with
with the talent that we had on screen
and off screen um all of the stunt crew
the producers the director like robert
schweinke is
a real true cinema file so if
if there's a chance to sort of go
through many variations of movies in the
future with
snake um i'm 100 on board it's
it's one of those characters that just
you know it's a it's a one in a million
um and i think people are going to be so
amazed and so
happy when they finally get to see this
you know we've had it in our back pocket
for uh for many months
um waiting to release it uh in the
cinemas because it needs that release
people need to see the grandeur they
need to see
the expanse of what we're trying to
build out um
to get them hyped for the rest of the
universe that we've got planned
are there multiple snake eyes helmets
like is there one
with without like how do you see through
that that's something that's always
wondered about the character in general
it's like is that thing see-through how
do you what's what is going on with the
helmet
you can see through it there's there's
very there's very sort of uh
as a prop there's very sort of like fine
slits through the uh through the visor
so you're kind of like looking a little
you know people are kind of like are you
looking at me are you looking up here
um but no the visibility is pretty good
but um
in terms of uh movievisor you'll have to
wait and see
which makes it even more impressive to
think you're doing all that stuff with
the helmet on
finally you know you you mentioned
something i thought was really
interesting you and andrew both the only
half asian guys
for in the communities that you grew up
in yeah um
we're in a year now where there's this a
real social awakening
and we're hoping that things last as we
push forward and you've been at the
front of this for a while with crazy
rich agents and you're here now
um with snake eyes what does it mean to
you that um
it's funny to say this but finally
people are paying attention to asian
characters that are
full characters 300 history characters
um that are fully developed
and can be seen in so many different
ways as heroes
as villains um what does it mean to you
to be able to represent that in uh
in the movies i mean it's a it's an
absolute honor to be
sort of put on that kind of
wall of names that have have been trying
to push forward
um this kind of movement in in hollywood
uh you know there's
many many people that have come before
us there's gonna be many
sort of um young faces uh coming after
us but i think
really the momentum the momentum is so
important to keep going
um you know the bug doesn't stop at
crazy rich asians the bug doesn't stop
um you know snake eyes uh warrior
andrews amazing
series it doesn't stop with sandra oh
you know we have to build
upon what we have um and keeping that
momentum
sort of going and we have to get to a
stage where
it's not a spotlight anymore you
understand
it's not a movement it is reality
that's where we're trying to normalize
the fact that we see these people
on screen that they have
three-dimensional characters they have
three-dimensional stories
um and that starts from the grassroots
starts from the writers
the idea makers the producers um it
starts from the communities
um and it starts from the people heading
to the cinema
you know it's it's hard to say but uh
essentially you vote with yours your
your ticket stuff at the theater like if
you want to turn out for these movies
you want
bigger and better ones like turn in that
ticket stop
um put bums in seats shout out loud on
twitter
add to the movement add to the sort of
the
the vocalness of everybody um
and you know it's an absolute pleasure
to be
able to play some small role in that if
we inspire
a kid halfway across the world to be
like you know what
i don't care what anybody says i'm going
to do the best i can
i'm going to aim high i'm going to dream
bigger
you know our job is is just so worth it
if that's the case
fantastic thank you so much man henry
such a pleasure to talk to you
as an action movie fan there's so many
things to be excited about
with this for me so i can't wait to see
it buddy
you